welcome to the across the spoiler vers
podcast I'm your host Paul as always
join with Greg what why do you look so
sad Greg because Paul the subject of
today is making me sad I feel sad Paul
yeah I feel a bit sad to be honest
hiding it with a little bit of humor
before I get really emotional today it's
going should we just get it out the way
and just talk about it now um so
unfortunately guys it's bad news um
we've I've been thinking over the
weekend um I had a long message in chat
with Greg and we've decided that we're
going to kind of take a foot off the gas
on this podcast um and not go with it
every week um I don't want to get too
far into it but mentally I've just been
so drained and burned out from
everything just going on in my life
right now um and just looking at the
podcast uh I feel like it's not
necessarily the way that I wanted to go
with it when I first thought about
starting up the podcast and that's for a
number of reasons um like it's taking
over quite a lot of my life I know it's
taking over a lot of Greg's life um the
way we're having to record with the time
difference that's very difficult and
just the general feeling on of it it's
when I when I started it up I wanted to
be like we'll do a positive show every
week we'll get through the strikes and
we'll constantly be bringing good news
and I do feel like positivity is the
main thing that I wanted from my YouTube
channel but I feel like just the way
we're covering topics the kind of Raad
that we've gone down it the I mean maybe
starting in the middle of a strike
during one of the worst years ever for
box office performance that's you know
when when there's lots of war going on
and the the cost of living crisis is
terrible as well maybe it was going to
be a difficult time to make it positive
but I just feel like from an outside
point of view people will look at the
podcast and think why is this guy so
negative all the time why is he hating
on it and though we've tried to be as
optimistic as possible I feel like it's
kind of taking away things from what I
wanted and mentally it's it's very
draining um for example like last week
with the Jonathan Maes thing you know I
didn't really want to I didn't stop the
podcast to talk about those sort of
things because I don't necessarily feel
equipped to deal with them um and it's
not just stuff like Jonathan major
there's a lot of things every week that
we're talking about that I don't know I
just don't feel like I'm the right kind
of person to handle those things you
know I want to be making jokes in making
people smile um and it has been quite
draining on
me I I don't want to sound like I'm a
victim because I have had a lot of fun
with Greg but I just ba basically
messaged Greg and said look um you know
I'm not really getting to see my family
much this this has cost like it's taking
a lot of time away from that and
mentally I just feel like it's sort of
it's not the direction that I wanted to
take and I'd rather be going in a
positive direction instead of heading
heading down this negative path that we
constantly seem to be doing we noticed
it in the views as well whenever we try
and do a positive week it would do
terrible so we'd then go like oh well
should we go with a more negative
headline this week and we do that and
the views would be better but on a on a
personal level I don't get enjoyment out
of going down that route um and I know
I've been joking about ending the
podcast loads of times it was literally
just a decision over the weekend that I
swear down and I know if Greg might be
doubting me but I said to him look I
even swear that this has not been
something that I've just been for weeks
now and it just I had a we've got a a
mutual business partner that we kind of
sound off to and and get advice from and
I had a meeting with them on Thursday
and they they were saying you know what
is your what things are are you finding
difficult with work what direction would
you rather be going and yeah just kind
of hit that point I mean even the
classic movie breakdowns I started
because I realized that I was being a
bit too harsh on movies and I and it was
reflecting NE negatively on the channel
and I wanted to see series every week
where i' be I'd have something good to
say about films and yeah it just kind of
felt like that um so we we have decided
that we are going to still do the
podcast but it won't be weekly and
that's purely because every week we're
having to gather whatever stories are
out and often times you know more times
than not they're not things that we
would normally cover but we're having to
fill a podcast slot and come up with
these things that we might not
necessarily want to talk about or if we
do talk about we still don't feel like
we're fully equipped or researched well
enough to deliver it to what you guys
deserve so going forward we want to do
one for June in
March June June part two in March not
June the month in March um and we're
just going to kind of do it as and when
if there's a big story that we can talk
about we think we'll drop it then and
hopefully that builds anticipation with
you guys as well um instead of us just
every week popping up with oh here's
what's been terrible this week hope you
guys enjoy it and feel better at the end
of the podcast so yeah Greg is anything
you want to say goodbye so it's not our
last episode but it is kind of our last
scheduled episode that makes
sense uh I want to take this opportunity
to announce my podcast with mt that I am
starting up and I can't wait for all you
guys to go check it out it's going to be
debuting right here on the heavy
spoilers
Channel no uh I I I I really do enjoy
doing this like there's there's a lot of
behind the scenes conversations like
Paul's one of my closest friends uh
especially in this space you know like
there's only so I think with any line of
work that anyone has the only people who
can really identify with you are people
who are in that line of work people can
always empathize or kind of understand
um but you know like this is this is a
weird gig that we have uh being people
who make YouTube
videos and you know when starting up
this podcast the the way how it's coming
to a conclusion is the same way how it
started Paul messaged me one day we
should start a pod and then the next day
we're doing a podcast it was like
instantaneous oh here we are and I had
no idea what we were really walking into
and it it it's been such an interesting
Journey for me on my personal end uh
that I was uh explaining to Paul
yesterday about how you know when this
started I wasn't really sure what we
were going into and most of my life I've
kind of been like a supporting player
and then having real Rejects I had to
learn how to lead and I got so
comfortable leading that coming back to
here and then meeting on someone else's
Channel I was like okay it took me like
a few recordings to get comfortable to
learn how to be uh supporting again and
on top of that too the the other
obstacle that we run against is that you
know like one of our favorite podcasts
is like weekly Planet both Paul and I
share that uh love and enthusiasm for
weekly planet and they record in like
the same room and I noticed that there
there is a barrier that can happen um
not just in like literally in the in the
term of like internet connection so we
have to like really pause we don't
interrupt we try not to because because
of those facts there's been like other
variables that I've been like enjoying
the challenge of overcoming of learning
to be comfortable on someone else's
channel is a main support and learning
how to be a supporting again and just
being here has been very it's been very
enjoyable for me and it's like none of
this is at all a blame uh towards like
the audience like you only watch when
it's negative it's it's because you know
we we didn't we're not like brand new to
this and I think there's a part in our
brain that we didn't let go of because
it's allowed us to re-evaluate a lot of
stuff about what we really like doing
like we we know that we can chase like
negative clickbait kind of stuff or rage
bait um on our own personal end all the
time but we unfortunately and I've had
this talk with Paul too like we're not
sociopaths where we can just completely
elim like of um detach ourselves from
that especially if it's not coming from
a sincere place that you know if we're
if we don't like something we'll be
honest about it if we hate something or
whatever we'll be honest about it of
course but we don't really want to just
feed that bubble unless we really feel
like a calling to talk about something
um and and I at the end of the day we
just do get it does affect us mentally
and and and emotionally and we we even
when like the views are great it's like
we
yeah you know like you you've talked to
me about like how like the Johnny Depp
trial even covering that for you which I
totally get what you mean is how like
yeah they did great numbers you made
good money off those videos but there
was just something about the feeling
that it left you with that didn't feel
quite good and yeah yeah so like
stepping back I think we followed
algorithm and [__] but then through
following algorithm like oh crap we've
kind of set ourselves in this direction
that we didn't really want to be in yeah
yeah like I I really want to make work
that I'm proud of um because I did so
many years of just putting out content
for the sake of putting out content we
kind of hit a point now where we don't
have to do that and my my working day is
basically get up 6:00 a.m. um finish
about 5 o'clock but when we're doing the
podcast that you know 6 a.m we finish at
5: sort out stuff with the kids and then
come back to record at 8 and then by the
time I get to bed it's 11: a it's 11:00
p.m. and then back up the morning 6:00
a.m. to get the podcast edited and
finish by 5:00 and then
just my whole week is like that and then
we've been doing longer videos so we're
getting lots of copyright strikes and
claims so I've got to re-edit stuff and
I've often been working into the weekend
and it's just kind of what I don't when
we're pushing these out and stuff I
don't necessarily feel proud and it's
even gotten to a point where I don't
even share the podcast on Twitter
anymore because I'm just I don't feel
proud about the the the way I'm handling
subjects necessarily and the way that
I'm kind of going off on things so yeah
unfortunately we've decided to bring it
to a close in terms of weekly and just
do it as and when we hope you still stay
subscribed because we will obviously be
dropping stuff again thank you for all
your support you know we started this
back in May um when the strikes were
just starting and we know you guys have
been rocking with us every week it has
meant a lot and we we've kept coming
back and I do genuinely feel bad because
I don't like letting people down um and
I was talking to my wife about it
yesterday and she said Paul your biggest
problem is that you're a people pleaser
and you will just keep on trying to
please everyone and when that doesn't
happen you NE you feel like you really
let them down and you just need to stop
and I am still going to be producing
videos and stuff obviously and we will
still be having these chats but even
like Echo I've had that over my head for
a month because I didn't like it and we
we got it at the start of December and
I've just known that backlash is coming
from it and just when I dropped my
review Twitter went wild with it I was
getting called loads of stuff um and
yeah there was even people jumping in
being like this guy hates all MCU stuff
he made he said loky was terrible and he
said what if was terrible and I was like
you're just making up stuff in your head
about me that I loved Loki yeah and you
get a weird thing on on social media
often where you get like people who just
come up with a version of you in their
head and and that'll be what they
project insults onto and stuff and it's
just kind of this I felt this podcast
was adding to that um judging by some
things so unfortunately uh we're put
into it but we we appreciate all you
guys support and we hope you enjoy our
last quote unquote last episode because
we've got a lot to talk about the first
of that being Greg we're going to go in
a positive direction what were your
thoughts on echko it seems to be quite a
mixed bag and I feel like I'm actually
in the minority saying that it's bad um
but I'd like so I'd like to start off
hearing your positive thoughts on it I
liked it I I understand I know that we
we don't often the funny thing about it
is you and I when we message each other
we often have a difference of opinion
it's R it's actually kind of rare for
Paul and I to be exactly on the same
page about when it comes to like movies
and shows and for Ekko uh I it was one
of those things looking back I don't
know I I consume so much stuff that I'm
now trying to jog my memory on like what
the experience was like the what I
recall from the experience of watching
that series was that yeah I could see
all the flaws I thought it got better as
it went long but I actually really
enjoyed the look of the show a lot I
enjoyed the tone I The Supporting Cast
really really worked for me um a lot uh
I do think that yeah they could have
done more to enhance the Maya Lopez
character uh but by episode four I I
actually really liked I remember alaka
Cox's performance in episode four I was
very much connected to that I in the
first three that was my main concern of
you know I'm liking The Supporting Cast
there's elements I'm liking but it's
that my Lopez character I'm just not
connected to and then the fourth episode
I remember being very much drawn to her
body language um everything about her
expressions and I think maybe it comes
down to the direction and while the ep
the final episode does you know succumb
to the pitfalls of what you sort of
expect from a Disney plus Marvel series
at this point where everything's just
kind of feels a little bit rushed and
truncated and trimmed down I was already
hyper aware of that before going into it
because of the original episode
announcement so it was kind of a unique
experience for me after you know
factoring in all the Disney Plus shows
that have come before and then watching
this one where I was still surprised by
how ultimately the tone of the the final
episode managed to still feel unified in
spite of the fact I how I kept going man
I really felt like we could have used
more flashbacks with Kingpin I feel like
we could have fleshed this out this
whole story line with Bonnie kind of
just like came and went nothing really
amounted to it like I could see all the
things that were like constantly getting
cut down and you could even see that
sometimes in the editing of that final
episode alone like I I remember
specifically when Maya gets the text
about uh her those people missing and
she like shows up and then it just cuts
to her running with the gun I was like
oh there's definitely like missing beats
here but I still thought they gave I
felt like the filmmakers were forced
into a
position where they had a studio mandate
and they thought how do we still make
this feel like a unified tone still
complete whatever this story is that we
have for this particular season and what
scenes even though there are other part
there are certain scenes that definitely
feel trimmed down and cut up they I
thought they focused on just the right
amount of they focused they knew what
scenes to focus on enhance that and
magnify to let those scenes shine so
ultim ultimately I thought the good
outweighed the bad for me I thought it
kept episode five was on the lower tier
for me out of the
episodes but I was still like it's no it
was the the way it was nowhere near as
bad as it could have been considering
all the behind the scenes factors now
yeah am I giving it a pass due due to it
yeah but I can't as from my subjective
viewing experience I can't just
eliminate that from my mind like I'm
aware yeah it's difficult when we know
so much yeah and so watching it you know
I was I was surprised by it and I felt
like Maya could have still done a little
bit more like i' I've definitely got my
criticisms for the show like I I covered
all five episodes and I talked at at
extensive length per episode on on on
real rejects but in summary yeah uh
every every almost every criticism I've
heard uh I've been like yeah kind to me
the show just went from really good to
Mid that's where it constantly went for
really good to Mid and uh ultimately I
was like yeah I liked it and I I feel
like this I would have been upset if
Kingpin got his ass whooped again you
know I actually kind of like he kind of
did he didn't get his ass kick I mean he
got like this emotional court that I
feel like could do something to the
character got better helped I'm sorry he
got better helped on the psychic plane
yeah that's a good way to put it yeah my
issue was I felt like it was Netflix
when you order Netflix from wish and I
just stood up to get these down Greg
these are how much I love the Netflix
shows I've got bloody Luke Cage
steelbook Iron Fist Jessica Jones I've
got two bloody Daredevils right that's
how much I love it yeah it takes more
effort for me to take that out the case
and put it in the the Blu-ray player and
turn that on than it does to just press
the Netflix button on my remote you know
what I mean but I've still got them and
I was really excited when I saw the the
first trailer for EO I thought here's a
show where they've taken the Netflix
characters they've brought in an MCU
character and Echo they're going to push
them all together and they're going to
really really push it but I just think
that should be the bar I think Netflix
should be the bar and they should be
trying to get to that I don't feel like
they got anywhere close to it I feel
everything was substandard in comparison
to it the one shot fight didn't quite
match up to how it is in Netflix
kingpin's Arc and just in general like
yeah I know they had 13 episodes and
stuff in those shows but each character
will get an arc in that so you know
Karen paage will have one where she's
kind of off doing her own thing and
having to kill someone and foggy will
get an AR um and I don't feel like you
know the people who set the the their
five budget limit the five episode limit
in the eight episode thing that it
originally was before they then cut it
down they're deciding how long these
seasons are and I think they should have
took a good look at that say so how does
this work and push towards that and
really make an actual TV show instead of
just doing what Marvel tend to do which
is that that they'll try and do
basically what's a three-hour movie that
they cut up into episodes and I just
felt it fell flat in terms of character
development everything was sort of
underdeveloped even how Kingpin survived
you know that was one of the big
questions coming out of Hawkeye how's he
being shot in the head and still
survived and they just skip over that
stuff um and don't really give us a
backstory another example I thought of
was how they open episode one which is
with the the whole um backstory of the
Native Americans what they believe and
their religion and stuff but I didn't
watch that and feel like I learned
anything because it was so rushed and
they didn't really go into it and I
think the representation in the show was
good but I'm trying to get attached to
this stuff and and learn about it and
they're not really giving me the
information that they should be able to
do in a TV show you know Avatar it's set
on Pandora and like a make believe
planet and I feel I know more about that
because of what's conveyed in the same
amount of time than what I did in this
because everything's just kind of rushed
through it's like oh you you have to
know this stuff because of you coming as
a like I'm an English man you know we
don't get taught any of this stuff in
school and I feel like it you should be
sort of brought in at a ground level if
you don't understand and yeah it was
just it was just feeling underdeveloped
and I think that first episode
especially kind of lost me because there
was I've just recently watched hawkey
again and I just felt like there's way
too much that they're cobbling from
Hawkeye to make an episode here when
they should really be having it as a
smaller recap standing on its own two
feet and then kind of going from there
um and yeah it's just it's just sad to
see because I think these MCU shows on
the whole have disappointed quite a lot
from where I'm coming from and to to
have the bar at where Netflix were and
expected to be at that
level it just didn't live up to it in in
any way across the board I don't feel I
don't think there was anything that
really stood out to to me in terms of
action that lived up to it
characterization that lived up to it and
it was all kind of just a sort of tone
back Netflix show when it should have
really been at least at that level I
think if youd released say say you took
this show went to an alternate universe
and dropped it on Netflix as like a
season one I think this would probably
come out as being like next to Iron Fist
in terms of quality where people would
rank it um I think because because it's
got you know the Marvel Studios Banner
with it people are giving it bit more
benefit of the doubt and you know riding
with it a lot more um but to me it just
kind of yeah just it took a character
I'm interested in and just went in a a
direction that like how many characters
in the MCU now just shoot energy beams
and have those kind of energy powers I
feel I feel like when we look back at
the old MCU like the phase one you had
Iron Man with his suit you know Thor's
got his hammer Captain America's got his
shield the Hulk's a big green giant you
had a real you had lots of different
powers and even in something like The
Infinity Gauntlet you know it's cool to
look at and you know the 10 Rings even
Ms Marvel I know people have problems
with those power changes but she's got
Bangles and stuff but it's kind of
getting to the point where you've got
the eternals who all shoot like energy
beams Captain Marvel who shoots energy
beams Photon who shoots energy beams and
now there's energy coming from Maya and
it's kind of like that there's not the
creativity there that I feel there once
used to be and even in things like the
Myers suit I know for example if you
look at some of the suits in the MCU you
can tell they've looked at comic books
and created those suits for those films
based on like different designs and
stuff whereas this is completely new and
it's obviously just been made by a
costume designer because there's not
really that that flare to it and I know
it's it's based on Ancient dress and
stuff but it's not it doesn't like pop
you know what I mean it doesn't feel
like a sort of comic book brought to
life feel feels kind of like a costume
designer has just put stuff together and
being like right right there that's it
and I I feel like they could have done
more I I I don't disagree with a lot of
what you said I feel like you have a
it's totally fun people do yeah you have
a it's like the standard that you went
in wanting was like Netflix standard and
I was more like this is a Disney Plus
show that was gonna be Netflix Jr is is
how I I I just knew that prior to going
to watch it and then I heard like bad
things before so of course that's going
to affect like my expectation level and
my desire for what I want this show to
be and I agree with you too on on Echo
one of my biggest complaints about the
character was that while I liked um her
performance especially in episode four I
thought I'd carry through episode 5 is
that she didn't really do anything to
earn those Powers it it was just she
learned and about some stuff and then
suddenly she has all these powers and I
thought they could have done something
whether it's because I feel like the
show was presenting this choice in terms
of the writing you you know how in the
in the beginning of the show it says
written by and there was always like
five writers and I always got the
impression that they like con it was
because they had to condense several
episodes into once that's why there was
like five writers on every episode and I
and I think they wanted to set up
something with like Maya Lopez dealing
with her past and confronting whether or
not she is going to be good or bad you
know so that was like the dichotomy of
choices in episode four that I thought
was really strong between learning of
her linear when she's with her grandma
and then talking with Kingpin so it's
like which path do I end up choosing and
while the the choic is made there still
seems to be this like sort of lack of
reconciliation that I thought was
missing for the character and on top of
that earning the powers but in terms of
the Chaka Nation people I actually
really like the way they were
represented here not just on an
aesthetic level I I felt like what they
did such a good job doing was making the
present day community of the chock top
people
feel very much alive like it was
something that just sort of resonated
throughout and I feel that with a lot of
Disney Plus or Disney in general you
know they the joke of the South Park me
of panderers that usually feels like
it's just pandering plating and this to
me felt genuine it it seemed like it was
actually inhabiting the world and with
the flashbacks I actually got a good
amount from it not the first one with
the very first chalk to lady was very
much mystical but you like the game that
they play in episode two getting an
impression like it's more again it's
more like uh tonal emotional based than
it is um you know expositionally laid
out and then in episode three where they
do it were like the old school film um
with that character they really
establish it and then by the time they
get to five where they explain like what
they were doing I okay it really that
actually
surprisingly worked for me would I have
liked more sure but I I still felt like
the chak Tod Nation they inhabited like
the entire Vibe of of the show and whe
whether that be past but mainly present
day and and that was something I did not
expect to really um latch on to when
watching it which I thought again like
really helped Elevate The Supporting
Cast like who while I I do agree like
man there's some missing arcs here and
and I kept I give some forgiveness
passes only because I was so aware that
like Disney made them trim this [__]
down and it's so obvious but it wasn't a
yeah editing disaster or in the likes of
like secret Invasion like I think this
finale works better than the secret
Invasion finale because yeah I I would
rank it above secret Invasion um I just
feel like you know marvel should be they
know that people losing interest in the
franchise yeah and they should be aiming
High it shouldn't just be a case they
know what the bar is they've had the bar
shown to them so many times by Netflix
on what these TV show should be andt
bring I think I think the excitement
that a lot of people have for this stuff
Netflix is actually doing a lot of the
heavy lifting our excitement for born
again I think the excitement for Vincent
ando's Kingpin I think if you just watch
this in a vacuum and this was like this
is your first introduction to Vincent
ino's kingpin You Might kind of be like
ah well I don't see what all the hype is
about I think Netflix are doing a lot of
the heavy lifting here especially going
forward and I think that Marvel have
actually realized that they need to be
better and that is why Daredevil born
again is getting worked up from the
ground up um and we've actually heard
this week that both the actors behind
Karen paage and foggy Nelson they're
coming back um so in case you guys
didn't know in the original the original
thing that they were doing for born
again they were actually going to be
killed off screen um and episode one
would start off with us learning that
they're dead uh wouldn't have went down
well I don't think at all but nope um
Deborah anwell and Elden Henson are
returning officially but Daredevil born
again and I hope that Elden Hensen and
Deborah and Willer texting those
original showrunners going I live [__]
because doing that it just it just shows
me like there must have been something
going on at Marvel at the time for them
to not realize that was going to be a
bad idea and I'm glad that they've
actually you know put stuff in place and
I think Ekko is I don't think it's the
last show that we'll have where it's got
these problems of the the
previous the way they were doing stuff
and obviously they they're getting shers
in place now and show Bibles I don't
think it'll be the last one but I think
it's at this point that they really
started realizing crap we're losing our
audience where just the these Disney
Plus shows are are diluting the product
um and we need to start pushing more and
being better they shouldn't just be mid
telev TV shows they should be you know a
talking point something people are
really excited to see instead of being
like a oh drop it and hope no one
notices and hopefully you know we still
have our hardcore fans who'll give it
goodwi of mouth but I don't know if
General audiences are on board I I do
feel like I'm in the the minority of
disliking it um but yeah it just doesn't
seem to have caught the the world on
fire um in the same way that the MCU
shows used to one division's actually
released three years ago today um as of
recording this and yeah just looking at
how stuff's changed it it it is a bit
weird I think you know Chris from 3C fil
he he said something on his review of
echo that I think really sat with me and
that is
that if Kevin FY canceled all of the
upcoming Disney Plus shows right now it
might be a better move um and it might
actually you know if they just said look
we didn't experiment with these shows
they some worked some didn't and we've
decided to just go back to movies I
think the franchise might be in a better
state but I I do are genuinely worry
about some of the the thing Daredevil
born again I am genuinely sort of
worried about I'm glad they're reworking
it I'm glad they're getting these
characters back but um I'm just yeah I
just don't know if Disney can handle it
and and take what I loved about that
those first shows and do it justice
Netflix at this point to me or the king
of the streamers um I think Disney you
know they they did try and they they
could have got close um but the strategy
that they're doing at the moment I just
don't see how they beat them and I think
just the way they tackle their shows and
handle them and they they would never be
like uh we we'll butcher a show and just
kind of get it out the way um which it
kind of felt like Marvel did with this
born again's the first one with a
showrunner right they're the first ones
that will actually have an actual
showrunner yeah so we've still got
Agatha House of Harkness or whatever
it's called this week coven of chaos I
can't remember they change the name
every other week um there is Ion har
which wrapped in November 2022 and won't
be released until November 2025 which
that doesn't fill me with a lot of
confidence and we've got X-Men 97 that's
Spider-Man show I think the animated
shows are probably that you know you can
people are more forgiving towards them
um and I think they'll probably do do
fine I think they'll be you know solid
entries but there'll not be something
people necessarily look back on their
watch throughs in five years time and
are like I need to go back through those
cartoons as well um so yeah it's it's a
bit of a weird
future I think yeah what do you kind of
Echo I'm I'm creating engagement Paul
it's the last time I get a create
engagement guys what did you think about
Echo leave it in the comments below
engagement yeah I I think it was just
the potential there I could see that the
Miss potential a lot on display and it
was just kind of like okay you got you
you know you did okay but there there
was so much more that you could have
done and that's how I left feeling it
even the stuff with Kingpin I'm thinking
Kingpin is meant to be this street level
Thanos villain now that we've heard
about and I don't even think he's a
preschool level Thanos you know what I
mean Greg it's kind of the guy's been
beaten by Eko twice Kate Bishop's
already beat him I don't I don't see how
Daredevil struggled with this guy for
three seasons I think you put him
against Spiderman he's he's done he he's
not making it out of a fight he's not
making it five seconds with Spider-Man
this guy so it kind of feels like they
dropped the ball on that as well and
yeah I'm I'm going to try and stop
complaining about it because we've got
other stuff to talk about so you say
something nice ended that um I I feel
like Vincent denafo still gave his aame
and still had opportunity to I I think
his work in episode four was the closest
we've come to getting like the Kingpin
that we've been really missing and I I I
do agree that you know that he's a
Thanos street level guy and and this
show did not really demonstrate that
because if you think about it you know
he he loses in in Daredevil season 1 and
season 3 he he loses in both Seasons but
it's it's the damage he inflicts and you
see all the [__] that he pulls in season
one and three to still make him feel
like the ultimate threat to the point
where when he to beat him feels like a
real obstacle feels like a real
Challenge and this did not quite do that
but I I'm I'm I'm holding out hope
especially because they have a
showrunner it seems like they're
listening to the fans and it's not the
same showrunners as the Netflix one uh
however I I do I mean the other all the
other shows you listed I have a concern
about because they're still part of the
same camp of when [__] was being
produced and written and made and blah
blah blah but but Daredevil specifically
I I feel like they they're going to be
putting their best foot forward to make
sure this one really works and who knows
who knows who knows who knows I'm I'm
I'm my the positive thing I could hold
out for is that because I have a
showrunner because theyve announced this
thing with bringing back foggy and Karen
uh that I have optimism for it
only you know if someone is has made a
mistake and realizes it and tries to
rectify it that and I yeah I am I am
glad they've done that and I think you
know that quelled my worries a bit it's
quelled that my worri is the right word
for that but it is now um yeah and
obviously you know another Disney
property that's in the similar sort of
boat is Star Wars where that's seen
dwindling viewership and fans just
constantly complaining you know back and
forth a backlash it's like its own Civil
War H last week on the podcast Greg I
talked about how John favro should be
put in charge of something because he's
just a great guy and the next day um
when we when we pretty much put this
live publicly the the Mandalorian and
grou they announced that they're heading
to the big screen which will be directed
by John fa and produced by favro
Kathleen Kennedy and Dave filon the
Mandalorian and grou will go into
production later this year this is the
way so it was classic Lucas film which
is when they get a bad headline which
was coming off the back of the whole
discourse about the the ray movie and
then uh yeah they they announced this
and I am I am excited I think that it's
kind of the the Mandalorian we we've
talked about this before where you know
The Season's viewership is declining and
I think the best way to kind revived
that and go out with a bang is just do
it on the big screen and just get it out
there you can get characters like LC in
it you can have DH Harrison Ford or
something I don't know if you'll sign on
to it but you've got a big opportunity
here to tell a a story that kind of
takes us into a new Direction and I
believe that John Fabro is the best man
for the job the guy created the
Mandalorian um he also has done wonders
at Disney you know I don't really like
the Lion King live action remake but
it's done a billion for them jle B
directed Iron Man played the happy Hogan
the guy is
fantastic I I remember when we first
talked about this I was very much
apprehensive about it because
of I'm of two minds about it I was at
first I was really apprehensive about it
because I was like well you know I feel
like they try to jam-pack a lot into
that you're probably going to be asking
a lot of your viewers to have to watch
all these seasons and and the the list
goes kind of on and on when you look at
what they doing the shows of how it
feels like they maybe didn't have enough
time but at the same the shows are weird
because they they they can usually have
two very opposing feelings they they
didn't have enough time to tell
everything they wanted to tell or they
really stretched the [__] out when it
did not need to be this long it's like
usually one or the other and I'm excited
for this now because when thinking about
what I was first saying is like do I
still have some of those concerns that
they might try to jam-pack with a little
too much like a season's worth into a
two-hour movie
sure but you know watching the show
Mandalorian even certain aspects of a
sooko but specifically Mandalorian they
really throw down for the visual
department where a lot of that sort of
deserves to be seen on the big screen
and not just on a television so with
that in mind I'm like yeah the spectacle
of it is pretty cool and the Mandalorian
is the first is if you can correct me if
I'm wrong I feel like that is the only
thing that has really been produced that
is an original character something
originally produced from the Disney era
that has for the most part been
universally praised unlike what's
happened with the trilogy Rogue one
Rogue one not necessarily original
characters it was more kind of like
we'll take an idea of something that we
know about we'll create characters for
that and then they'll go do it andle was
created for for Rogan but that's that
plotline still was kind of like it's in
a new hope you know that spies got the
plans of the Death Star basically um and
they went in like we'll fill in the gaps
with that we'll create characters that
go off and get the plans whereas
Mandalorian is kind of like we're just
telling a new story we're heading off
and just tell a new story about a new
Jedi with a new Bounty Hunter yeah a new
Boba Fett and he's gonna yeah so I get
what you're saying um but ahsoka's
obviously been quite a big character the
last year they also announced that
season two of that is now in production
officially and they posted some some
artwork from it where it was ahoka and
Sabine standing on the finger of the
statue that um Balin was on last season
and they were just standing on there so
leaning heavily into the mor guard stuff
I think that is kind of the the interest
that people had in in the last season
you know it originally started off those
was first three episodes it was who is
that guy I forgot his name now Greg but
he was another Mesto you know the one he
just turned out to be green gas in the
end the one with a mask I thought it was
Ezra G theories about it Marco Marco was
marrick maybe marrick completely
forgettable yeah nothing but we we had a
good three weeks out of that got getting
theories out there um but yeah the the
mortis guards obviously the Hayden
christens and stuff that was all kind of
the the bigger talking points towards
the end of the season and yeah I I am
excited for aaker I did I didn't like
remember I I was someone who slammed
those first two episodes I said this is
rubbish they're just recapping Rebels I
don't I don't I all know all this stuff
and they're just getting back to Rebels
and then from there yeah I thought it
really picked up I really enjoyed that
season um unfortunately Ray Stevenson
passed away um he was such a good part
of that season as well um but they got
Hayden back for it h they thwn was I
thought was brought in quite well you
know there was some flaws and how they
did it but yeah on on the whole really
enjoyed Ahsoka and and glad to hear that
there's a season two in production now
okay I mean I'm I'm h i I feel I feel
good about that yeah I'm positive about
it Paul goad might as well be yeah it's
well if you're you're positive about
that Greg I feel sorry for someone who's
going to be getting a lot of backlash
and this is Caitlyn Diva who has been
officially cast as Abby in the last of a
season two um so we did hear rumors
about that a while ago I remember
talking about it but please guys just
protect Caitlyn diva in case you guys
don't know Abby I would say Abby is
probably one of the most controversial
figures in gaming ever I cannot to the
top of my off the top of my head think
of someone who's more controversial um I
don't want to spoil the game because
it'll spoil the show because I'm pretty
sure they're doing the same thing there
but there's a lot of things going on
with her and Caitlyn
Diva I think uh I think she's you know
she's probably going to be getting some
heat once those a couple of those
episodes drop I think it's great casting
I know people whenever they announce
something like this the first thing
people talk about is like he's not musly
you needs to Superman's not jacked
enough they need to M muscle up but you
know you can do stuff with lighting you
can do stuff with CGI or the actor can
even surprise surprise work out and
exercise and build muscles themselves
Ryan rounds at the end of free guy you
know remember that character yeah should
look like that yeah I think um I think
the way they've done it is to kind of
reflect Ellie obviously Abby and Ellie
are similar sounding names um and they
also if You' played the games then you
know that you you play pot as Abby and
pot as Ellie and they both kind of have
these mirror campaigns almost um the
remaster is coming out on the 19th Greg
I know it's one of your favorite games
of all time it's one of my favorite
games of all time might even be up there
as number one but uh yeah the remaster
for the PS5 is coming out on Friday if
you've already got a copy of it on the
PS4 Greg I think you can upgrade it for
it's a bloody steal I'm getting that
straight away um yeah played through it
when the show was on loved it again um I
am excited to see what they do with it I
hope season two's got more more clickers
and more of the infected in um I think
that was probably my my fault with the
first season but it was still really
strong I remember texting new Greg and
being like I'm I'm three episodes in and
I think this is uh I think this is
better than the actual game then towards
and it was like wish I hadn't said that
I remember the parking lot I was in when
you it's that stood out to me so because
we had been going back and forth for so
long about why we low Last of Us so much
and then you were you had seen it before
me and you text I remember being in the
parking lot being like could that be
true is that is that a
real is that is that could that if
Paul's saying this this might be had
such like a moment of conf I remember
you saying it as well and we were like
it is it is it actually is good [__] in
her ultimately didn't turn into better
than the game for me but yeah I mean
like I think it's because they skipped
the horror stuff they skipped a lot of
the the like the basement in the hotel
come on how do you skip over that please
why is that skipped out that's like one
of the best bits in a game ever it's not
just that it's it's also like when they
they have a chance to actually create
some tension like I remember that the
time it really stood out to me I've only
seen the show Once but there was one
specific scene it's when um before the
big uh bloater episode happens that this
the level when Joel has to sneak around
the cars to get to the sniper they
create no tension out of that he just
goes around the left and then goes
inside the house and kill the guy and
and to me and even as just a viewer I I
think if if I hadn't played the game I
would have seen that moment and been
like why didn't they do anything with
that and as a fan of the game it's
especially disappointing and what I
think that they the thing that they do
miss out on and this is what I was
surprised by because in that first
episode they really brought the sequence
to life when they're driving around in
the car going around to town like like
scen by scene comparison you can watch
Paul's video where he does it it's
amazing they really brought this action
sequence to life yet the on ground stuff
when you're like fighting the monsters
or you have to like distract them or the
sneaking around that element of
cinematic adaptation they kind of just
did a bit of a I don't want to say
generic but it's borderline generic pass
on how to handle the action for it when
I'm like oh but you know visually there
is a a specific there there is a
specificity to the visual aesthetic of
how to do the action in the mood and the
tension and they they didn't it didn't
seem like they even attempted to really
do that and uh that's something that I
hope they do bring bring to life
especially for Last of Us two like that
is Last of Us two I I would argue is my
not argue it's my opinion it is my
favorite game of all time I'm pretty
sure it is uh my f I'm G tell that it's
not your favorite game of all time what
are you doing man my opinion oh yeah no
it's my f it is my favorite game of all
time and uh I I I know we can't talk
about spoilers but I I was kind of
vlogging my experience with it where in
the first 30 minutes the first day of
playing I did I remember vlogging being
like this is some manipulative ass
[__] I remember just saying that
like this is this is not working this is
so manipulative and then when I finished
it I was like I loved it more than the
first one so it's a challenging it's a
challenging experience and I'm excited
for it wins you around I think they I
think it's what we've criticized about
the show though they did have some good
human elements that they added into for
example the bill and Frank stuff episode
I mean is that was that up did that win
an Emy I don't know what the awards are
this week but I feel like it's that was
nominated for something and that was
great and just the things like making
Joel deaf in one year and the little
human touches that they added in I hope
they do it with that in season two I'm
guessing it's going to get split into
carrying over to season three I'm very
curious about the structure because
without spoiling the you got we don't
have to spoil I mean I feel like most
people who are listening at this point
probably play the game or know what
happens in the game um but without
spoiling it like you you play the first
half not the first half you play the
first third as Ellie then the second
third that go back in the same time
frame of where you start with Ellie but
you're playing as Abby and then you go
back to playing as Ellie and uh and so
there like there's time overlap and
there's a very specific structure so the
the thing to me that I'm most curious
about going into this season because I'm
sure like acting we'll just see how she
does I'm sure it'll be fine and like I
know like to me the physicality of Abby
is very important because it's very
demonstrative of who a character is uh
but the structure is I'm like how are
they they going to structure this are
they going to emulate exactly what the
game did because I don't know if that
will work for a show it would be very
Challen it' be be a cool way to
challenge the audience I think um for
those who haven't played the game but I
I I have no idea that's the part where I
am most intrigued of what are they going
to do Str I reverse it and I would have
most of season two Play Out From aby's
perspective and get you as an audience
to know her and like her as a character
and see how much a wonderful person she
is and then at the end she comes face to
face with L with the other characters
and you're like oh [__] who do I root
for because I really like this character
now and it's what you mean it's oh my
God and then cut the black just cut a
black after that big event boom piss
everyone off but it would be
dramatically newcomers would be like I
don't what the hell's just happened it
would be like a red wedding all over
again which won't spoil it it's not a
red wedding we'll just not spoil
anything
that is the tough part because you have
to get on board with her whereas in the
game you're forced to because you're
playing the game and you've already
committed this much time complete it
mate yeah so you're like might as well
but on a TV show you know certain things
could happen and you're like I don't
want to watch this anymore I'm done
watching you could lose viewers
basically um and and that's the that's
why I I keep harping on the structure
specifically because that that's
probably the smart that is a smart
Avenue to take get you first and do do
the flip of the game would probably be a
smart way to keep you watching
considering how important of a character
she is this is gonna be fun it's gonna
be a fun year man it's be a
controversial time on YouTube it's gonna
be a controversial enough for us Greg
we're giving it Up Moving
on but uh speaking of moving on actually
Tom Cruz has put out a tweet saying
excited to share this news I look
forward to making great movies together
and the Tweet was a link to Tom Cruz
joining Warner Brothers Discovery now
according to our good friends over at
the streamer uh reportedly tensions
reached a breaking point between Tom
Cruz and Paramount prompting his formal
deal with WD wbd he said he doesn't send
script Pages doesn't let them see
dailies he used to be very responsible
on budgets so from what I heard with our
Tommy he um he basically it was all all
of a Top Gun in stuff like that and
Mission Impossible so you might remember
during the the pandemic they wanted to
keep Tom basically wanted to keep
delaying Top Gun until it could be shown
in a cinema and whereas Paramount were
like just drop it digitally mate just
put it on a streamer for free but Tom
was like h no we not gonna do that don't
really talk like that like no we're not
gonna do that I can't do the The
Voice We're not gonna do that um yeah
and then apparently with the issue with
the mission imposs release was due to
par Mount and and Tom wanted to move it
but Paramount were like locked on that
date and even though Tom Tommy Boy was
like can we not do that uh they they
pushed ahead so I think those two things
kind of came together and he was like
I'm G to go work for somewhere else so
yeah big shot because he's been with
them for a hell of a long time um and
they actually have a third Top Gun movie
in the works at Paramount at the moment
before before the switch um with Aaron
Krueger on board to to reunite with
director Joe kazinski um Glenn Powell's
going to be returning Miles Teller as
well yep Top Gun three we're getting
that cool okay are really like the
second one let's do it well looks like
Tom Cruz really loved the flash that's
what got him here man that's why David
zasloff was like watch this movie you're
gonna want to join our company is a good
move for him this good move this is a is
a big win for Warner Brothers my God
that's a huge win they need a Tom Cruz
right now the guy's probably got like 10
more years of him yeah and from Warner
Brothers well according to the Hollywood
Reporter Warner Brothers is hoping that
Tom Cruz will start working on the edge
of tomorrow to that's quite a big one as
well yeah I really like that film um I
don't know if they're going to do the
the three titles that they had with the
the original release because it was
called Liv D repeat Edge of Tomorrow and
in I'm sure posted it and he was
watching it it was called All You Need
Is kill which I think was the original
name of the the Manga comic that was
based on or the manga I don't know I'm
not a big not big up on my Live Die
Repeat stuff and all these titles get
confusing mate I just remember I'm
constantly changing the title I've got
the 4K steelbook over there it says Edge
of Tomorrow on the side right but I know
from the cover that it's says lived Die
Repeat I'm like what what do I call this
movie what the hell do I call it did she
just call a sec Liv i r uh I I think uh
I think I think the trailer for the F
for Edge of Tomorrow what I remember
from that experience of why that movie
underperformed was it it was a terrible
trailer it just looked like every
generic Tom Cruz movie and did not sell
it everyone thought that and then the
movie came out and it ended up being
like wow this is so good this that was
that's a great film and it's it's it
it's different for a Tom Cruz joint
because we all know Tom Cruz for the
practicality and the stunts and stuff
but this like such a heavy and while
there is stun work involved like the
suits they wore wor have you done a
breakdown for that movie have you have
you done like going to got it on the
list that's why it's over there I
basically have a pile of Blu-rays on
there and it's just work down the
Blu-rays yeah and the reason why I don't
I'll say like one video I'll be like I'm
working on Terminator 3 next I'm working
on this next it's because I'll buy a
Blu-Ray watch it and be like putting it
on the pile so that's why wickerman is
like came out of nowhere and it's said
I'm working on that next H but yeah
brilliant film yeah um I I think it was
around the time of Oblivion when Old
Tommy Boy was kind of making those sort
of very generic looking sci-fi films
that people are like it was sort of
around the the pop the peak of the MCU
when all people cared about was comic
book movies and like I just want to see
comic book movies all the time they're
my favorite thing um so yeah interesting
that he's gone to Warner Brothers quite
a big shake up there probably is the
biggest star in Hollywood and for him to
move Studio like that Paramount must be
kicking themselves but there was
recently that talk as well that
Paramount and Warner Brothers were going
to be merging as well so maybe you'll
just send her back at Paramount still so
you try to escape you son of a [__] we
got you and that could be the plot of
like Mission Impossible 10 or whatever
him trying to escape Paramount but just
keep keep tracking them down I do miss
Tom
Cruz just performances though like they
listed Magnolia here and oh yeah he's so
good in that movie and uh you know even
something that was along the lines of
just collateral which does which has
like a couple of action scenes but
that's just a damn good performance from
him and I I missed that and I think like
at the end of the day we have to come to
terms with the fact that Tom Cruz is
getting older and there's only so long
he can endure like so maybe he has to
get like the last bit of the the action
movies out of his system for like the
next 10 years or whatever and do these
crazy stunts get your Top Gun three done
your mission impossible attend done get
it all done but he's he's got to go I
think he has to go back eventually to
just doing true like we watch it for the
performance and not just to watch Tom
Cruz risk his life you know and I I I
miss that because he gives good
performances still like even in those
movies like top gun Maverick I thought
he did an excellent job that I thought
that was a great performance but I I
think we I miss I miss that time of
that's me Tom Cruz big was the the
actual acting abilities you know Few
Good Men and then you went crazy with
the stunts you went too far with those
stunts Tom what are you doing hanging on
the side of an airplane are you crazy
crazy man crazy crazy man you should
have got AI to do it and speaking of AI
Greg oh bloody hell I don't know if
you've seen this stuff with sag after
have not but um yeah despite this comes
from the streamer again despite Lobby
against generative AI during the strikes
sag aftera have announced a partnership
with AI company replica on an AI voice
agreement so this will be for video
games I believe um and it's said to be
an ethical approach to using AI but I
tell you I follow some voice actors mate
and they were not Bloody Happy none of
them agreed to it none of them signed
off with sag and said let's do this it
just uh came out of nowhere and I
believe that you know sag just don't
want to go back on strike and I spoke to
someone in the they said yeah they just
FR franer these these aren't my word
these are alleged in case I get sued but
allegedly frania just wants residuals
and stuff and doesn't really care about
AI things so yeah what the hell was a
ethical
approach what what could that be we ask
you before doing it I don't know yeah
what is what the hell could an ethical
approach possibly be that makes no sense
to me unless unless like I'm
I know we can keep it going and we could
really rage bait this [__] out of it
from here on out yeah we could there
there is a there is a time where that
will happen with people I don't
understand this I'm literally looking at
it for the first time I didn't hear
about this sorry I'm delaying this but
we're towards the end of the podcast we
can have some some dead air here some
dead air here for people yep I got no
information this makes no sense I don't
understand it well that's why we end in
the podcast Greg I lied all
about answers for people so I've never
been more energetic in my life it's 9
9:00 p.m. now been working since 6:00
a.m. and I feel great doing this every
day um yeah so last story on the podcast
before we go to our whatever we want to
record
itel with yeah scream Neeve Campbell
said she's now open to returning to the
scream franchise under the right
circumstances no Neeve what are you
doing my girl she was my first crush my
first onscreen Crush Was neev Campbell
Wild Things Greg was it Wild Things wild
things I've seen I've seen the scenes
from wild things but I've never seen the
movie Wild Things but why would you
watch scenes from a movie without
knowing what's going on in them heard
bit strange teenage boy Greg heard about
some good scenes that he had to go check
out on his own time his private time you
know what I'm saying and I uh I remember
those scenes but one day I'll watch
reaction erection I'm just talking about
the Kevin Bacon scenes I just wanted to
see Kev bacon stuff I don't know any
about the nef I didn't care about any of
that Denise Richard [__] like it's all
about the bacon this nef cample News man
B and roll bacon roll the B bacon rap
hot dog right there uh the nef Campbell
scream franchise under the right
circumstances there are no right
circumstances no don't talk about this
right now NE Campbell this isn't the
time
money [__] I mean it is kind of her
franchise let's be honest when when she
got kicked off it was kind of like uh
what you're doing so I can't I can see
why with her there's there is that kind
of feeling of like well this is my [__]
and I'll I should have been included in
the first place I think they'd have to
pay her a lot but they've just had such
a PR disaster I think this is they've
clearly reached out to her to try and
get some good PR because I know a lot of
people I'm not a big scream fan if I'm
being honest I know but I know a lot of
people who will be more forgiving of the
the choices that have happened because
they've got NE back or neev we call a NE
Greg I feel like I've been pronouncing
her wrong the amount of actors that I
have different names for and I'll hear
like Jared letto and Jared Leo I tell
you the amount of times I've recorded a
video and I'm like how do I pronounce it
again what's his surname again I should
really know this stuff but because I've
questioned myself so much about it I
just keep questioning myself and Ne and
Nev Campbell is one of those names Greg
well you speak proper English though
you're British you got the proper you
got the what's the classic joke the you
say herb because there's a [__] H in
there that's the joke that I heard
forever yeah and so her herb
herb oh according to this she was
disappointed that Dewey was killed off
in Scream
five okay
what yeah spoiler alert sorry should
have up who hasn't seen scream
five seen uh do way dead yeah that's a
scream five was the the big reboot
wasn't it where it was just called
scream again yeah you should have called
it scream again instead of just scream
screaming I was I didn't love that one
as much as everyone else did I like
Scream Six a lot though I didn't love
that scream one I'm I'm a huge fan of
this franchise it was scream my fun fact
about me uh every Sunday after church
uh with my family because this came out
when I was like six or I want to say six
or seven and uh I had the V my dad would
like well my dad would do is he'd rent
laser discs I don't know if you guys
know they're like these
giant things that before DVDs there
these huge disc that would cost a lot of
money and they were not as good quality
as DVDs he'd rent them and then he'd use
a VHS tape blank one to uh essentially
record screen record laser disc yeah
and so he did that for scream for me as
a six-year-old boy not censored and I
watched it every Sun it was a weird
ritual of mine go to church we go to
this place called Pizza Guy grab pizza
sit down living room watch Scream so so
neev Campbell that's why she was my
first crush because I just watched that
movie religiously all the time but the
thing is I I didn't like with scream
with Scream five I I felt like neev
Campbell was so unnecessary in that
story
and so unless they do one where it's
very much like this is Sydney Prescott's
story then sure but I kind of feel like
we're done with this Sydney Prescott
story I feel like the movie's been
trying to the franchise been trying to
say that like her story's done she's got
a family now she lives with sexiest man
alive you know she's doing fine
now I mean yeah but she's sort of I
don't know they they kind of have her as
a jam Lee Curtis you know what I mean
you you can't really Escape I'm sure if
they reboot Halloween Jamie Lee Curtis
will be back it's just yeah it's a weird
situation without franchise I'm just
glad that I didn't grow up on it my
first crush Greg Kimberly from the Power
Rangers good one bit of trivia for you
guys there good one I also like jet from
Gladiators in the UK you you w know in
America but I know some of my UK heads
right now they sitting right now they're
like I remember I remember our jet on
Gladiators Saturday
night me yeah that's right yeah see her
I'm just Googling I don't know her name
how far I Lally Googled it to make sure
she's yeah she's gorgeous that wasn't
make myself sound stupid she's 53 we did
it Greg she looks very different so any
stories that you want to talk about for
the could talk about our loves our
celebrity loves okay uh yeah think
Cameron Diaz in The Mask oh my
God that was the day man this doesn't
get better Cameron Diaz in the mess that
was something special another weird
Crush of M I had this thing where I was
maybe because I was lonely in school and
you know to talk to girls I was always
drawn in characters like I saw Carrie
when I was really young and I I told
myself that in between scream I will
from Scream to car I would watch I I'd
watch a horror movie I was obsessed with
horror and then I I was like I would I
have like this rescue a girl syndrome as
a kid like that would be the way to do
it and then I realized like you
shouldn't have that mentality in real
life that will lead to some really bad
relationships but uh yeah that uh so
since he's spasic weirdly I would con I
would like had his weird crush on Carrie
the girl who's much maligned and
ridiculed and criticized and bullied
like that was my other random Crush that
I you want to Pro you didn't want to
join in on the bullying you were trying
to protect her she never fre out I had a
protecting like I would watch LA
Confidential and Russell Crow as the man
who would protect domestically abused
wives like yeah yeah I had the fantasy
of like being that guy now my wife just
protects me at all costs if someone's
being loud in the theater I I'm there
for for like the whole movie
contemplating like if they do it one
more they check their phone one more
time I'm gonna yeah I'll sit and I but
my wife I just I send her in she's my
night and shining armor I just do
something she does it she handles
business so she's my she's my warrior I
like get I have like a really short
temper with that stuff and I know that
if I just look like I'm a bit unhinged
people will just drop it and there's
been a couple of times I've just been
sat on a bus and some kids have been
sitting behind me tapping me on the
shoulder laughing and I've let it happen
a couple of times I've just turned
around and went stop doing that just
they've just stopped doing it so you
just have to look a bit unhinged like
you're having a really bad day and you
might snap you might just snap on those
kids and normally the acting does it a
lot for you there's there's the old
saying is you don't have to be confident
but if you know how to act confident you
can put on that facade that you are
confident and people think you're
confident I think it's the same with
bullying kids at the cinema Greg you
know they're sitting on their phone and
next time he's sitting in a cinema and
someone's on you know 10 year olds on
their phone and you're like um I'm
normally send my wife in but I'm going
to go crazy on this and but yeah I've
just been looking up Hot 90 Hollywood
Superstars Sandra Bullock was another
one Greg oh tell what Sandra Bullock in
speed I wish I was on that Bloody bus
don't care where what you mean it's got
a bomb on it I don't care just keep keep
me on this bus as long as possible with
Sandra Bullock keu get out the way I'll
I'll save
you wise was another oh Rachel wise and
The Mummy Returns oh yeah specifically
The Mummy Returns which I think she
actually
that she wanted to like like go more I
don't know if this is something my mom
just told me or if this is a fact but I
think it shows in the film that she
wanted to be more
like I don't don't know what the right
choice awards here is or something like
I want to look more physically
attractive instead of like librarian
girl or or something not to say
librarian girls aren't attractive um but
you know what I mean okay if they're
being bullied they are to you you have
to protect them leave this all in here I
I could use it cancellation now um yeah
it doesn't matter Greg we're not doing
it again next week so we can say
whatever the hell we want toally
stinking City like a hop from hell is
our unus anus right here you can say
whatever the hell we want let it let it
die um yeah I just want to end the
podcast oh sorry continue I got I got
nothing I mean I got Jennifer love you I
was gonna end the podcast by saying
Elizabeth Hurley who in the '90s if you
saw atin a Powers bedazzled as well
those two back to back like why have we
never had these conversations this is
this is our childhood this would have
helped the podcast Craig this is theek
this would have been the real heart and
soul these conversations is what people
would have turned back in for a bit yeah
take a trip down memory lane who women
Hollywood actresses in the 90s that were
really hot five hour podcasts of it what
they look like are they still hot yeah
let's
compare well the reason yeah I remember
Elizabeth Hy I got someone on Twitter
who just like makes fun of simps and
people who you know suck up to women and
I remember him the other week going like
posting Elizabeth Hurley's Twitter
account and just saying like you guys
need to check out the replies in these
because the amount of middle-aged men
that are just replying going M yummy and
haha just stuff like that and uh it's a
good read guys if you if you want to go
follow Elizabeth Hurley and just read
her replies to like selfies aty post and
stuff bit unhinged but you know it's all
love it's all positive
and great holy [__] she looks great
still my
God yeah I gota it's because she kind of
went to Hollywood and then ducked out
before it got too much yeah smart holy
crap good for you grant cheated on her I
think what the hell was that about yeah
yeah I think that was when I hit the
point of realizing that unfortunately if
men are going to cheat they're just
going to cheat and it doesn't matter how
hot you are I know a lot of women when
they get cheated on they'll be like why
is this happened I'm much better looking
than they are and unfortunately some men
they just they've got it in them and
they're just gonna do it and it doesn't
matter what it is about that look look
at Elizabeth Hurley guys yeah you know
what I mean cheating on that it can
happen to anyone it could be happening
to me right now Greg my wife time going
these podcasts JayZ cheated on Beyonce
man like yeah no it's it's wild when you
hear because it's easy to think like
what why would you do but then you you
know men just want the variety they like
they like the buffet they like the
choice and um and I also think that just
relationships just aren't based purely
on looks as well so you know what I mean
there's other factors going in there
that woman might have just been nice to
him for five minutes when he was in a
bad spot on his Instagram and you just
don't know so what what message I want
to leave you guys with is that be
careful out there and my wife's probably
listening to this and thinking is if
Elizabeth hly me me messages Paul the
marriage might be over because of the
way he's been talking about her but I
love my wife more than anything Greg and
that's how I'd like to in the podcast I
love your wife my wife had been a movie
superstar in the 90s I would have been
making a podcast about it and mentioning
it every week yeah I would have just
been doing
Vlogs I I think I should just do vlogs
of me going to prostitutes with my wife
and being like no to the prostitutes
yeah I love you okay well that's why we
stupped doing the podcast Greg did you
see all the Madame web marketing this
week I've been having a right laugh with
that with a Madam web Ocean Spray store
oh there like sexual like yeah yeah
Dakota oh he had a really funny tweet
about that yeah that was a hilarious
tweet that went viral that Greg proud of
myself for that that was a funny ass
tweet that's
really yeah uh I was getting so much
[__] from yeah I was getting so much
[__] from Eko just saying I didn't I was
disappointed in it um and then I just I
followed it up the next day with that
and I was like I'm back I'm back to
having a good time on Twitter yeah I
don't know if you guys saw but there was
a video of Dakota Johnson where it's
just basically he in a room and you're
saying I think you're going to enjoy
Madame web so much that you might see it
twice something and I swear to God
they're just going full on sex with this
this marketing they had a costume reveal
yeah if there like those commercials I
would catch at like 2 in the morning you
know on like television yeah it was like
an 80s dating video tape and if you guys
remember those yeah it's just like I'm
looking for a big hunk to take me out on
the town in on a bottle of Ocean Spray
cuz basically they revealed The Madame
Webb costume on a bottle of Ocean Spray
and uh yeah weird Sony you don't know
why you do this stuff but uh I'm down
for it and I was just contemplating
leaving my wife for that bottle of Ocean
Spray because that promo mate that promo
was Bloody sexy that had been released
in the 90s Craig me me and you when we
were six years old would have been like
Mom can I have a look at your phone to
just quick check Twitter for something
you've been on that 5 hours poll what
you looking at just a madame web
commercial I just like watching this
Madam web commercial in the bathroom mom
just leave me alone please my superhero
stuff that commercial is she does she
say she says uh you'll want to see it
twice it's like oh my God you know what
that means at first at first it's like
is this just Dakota Johnson the way she
talks and then that line made it go they
know exactly what they're doing they are
they 100% trying to real in that male
audience to just Google and be turned on
and and I don't know it might work it it
actually might work I mean you got like
her and Sydney Sweeney like those are I
I Sydney Sweeney makes one of those
adverts oh yeah oh my God I think the
marriage rate the divorce rate is just
going to Skyrocket yeah I don't see how
it
doesn't mam Webber ruining marriages
left and
right yeah dropping Valentine's day as
well oh imagine going to the the cinema
with you your date and Dakota Johnson's
just like I think you guys are gonna
want to stick around for the post credit
scene there's two and they're big and
juicy Oh shot I would just be in the
aisle yeah it's G be so pretty much
devolved into the worst version of the
podcast that we could have to be end on
our final note I strongly disagree I
think this is it's gotten better I think
I feel like it's making me reconsider
our decision po
yeah I'll happily work 12 hours a day to
talk like this at the end stupid sex
jokes the entire time yeah really gladly
do it all right well close this out man
let's let's let's send let's end it and
then we'll delete every video yeah thank
you guys for all your support hope you I
know we got we've got a lot of women who
listen to the podcasts at the end
they've probably turned off by now um so
you know hopefully you guys have had fun
with us since May it's been a long time
I don't know how many episodes we've
done I think it's in the 30s or 40s I'd
probably have to work it out but it's
still an all right run it's just yeah
just got too much guys took on too much
on my plate started doing 55 minute
breakdowns of No Country for Old Men and
being like I'm exhausted from doing this
and I've got a podcast at the end of the
day but we hope you guys have had fun
over the last couple of months going
through the strikes the UPS the Downs
the ins and outs of Hollywood we hope
you've learned some stuff I've learned
some stuff about you Greg especially
today in the last half hour oh yeah um
and it's all starting to make sense I
feel like I'm
closer yeah well we'll never get to hold
hands again like PE it's a bit sad that
we'll never get to do that I hope that
Riverside's got us on the right side as
well CU they sometimes just randomly
swap us around but we will try and be
back for June they'll probably be
you hold hands with your wife yeah the
whole June episode will just be going
like oh Zen she's beautiful she's
beautiful we're just going to turn into
like we might come back and do this when
we're like 60 years old and just be like
those women back in my day Elizabeth hay
I tell you that oh she was
beautiful um but yeah hope you guys have
enjoyed it I've enjoyed it thank you
guys so much for being here and thank
you for uh being on this run with us and
thank you to all who gave me a to
welcome me and let me find a Groove here
appreciate it very much and thank you
Paul I hope you'll still be my friend if
you want to follow Greg he's on real
rejects as well only took 30 podcast
only took 30 podcasts for you to say
these words see that little magnifying
glass that's not a magnifying glass at
the top there to zoom in on stuff that's
a search thing so if you click that
magnifying glass thing it won't magnify
the screen it'll take you to a little
box you can type in anything there and
it'll find it re today you could find
images of what she looks like
today but go to real rejects because I
know they've already looked at it I'm
exactly the same I know exactly what my
listeners were doing Greg because I do
the same thing as soon as someone says
like they look pretty good today I'm
like stop what I'm doing jump out the
car I'm driving 90 miles an hour jump
out yeah quickly Google what they look
like now be like yeah they look all
right back in the car so yeah real
rejects go check them out love you guys
much love much
love